Speaker 1: It's quite stunning, but not altogether
surprising how quickly the perspectives on
presidents present and former having classified
documents has changed given the recent news
about Joe Biden.
As a reminder for all the people emailing
me saying, David, why won't you talk about
the Joe Biden classified documents?
We've talked about it so many times at this
point.
Investigate Biden, figure out what happened,
figure out if there was wrongdoing.
But it is a totally separate case from that
of Trump.
And it doesn't mean you stop investigating
Trump because you're investigating Joe Biden
for a while when it was Donald Trump who had
directed staff to take hundreds of classified
documents to his house, who tried to use lawyers
to prevent giving them back, who had his lawyers
say we gave them back even though they didn't
give them back.
And everything that led up to the search warrant
being executed at Mar a Lago during all of
that time.
Right wingers were saying, this is a witch
hunt.
This is a paperwork issue, this is a non-story.
This is just something that happens and you
just deal with it.
And the documents you give back and then you
just move on.
You don't do all of this crazy stuff, including
showing up at Trump's house at Mar a Lago.
But now all of a sudden that it's Joe Biden
being investigated for something similar,
but not at all the same thing.
All of a sudden now they're talking about
treason.
That is not an exaggeration.
In this clip, I'm going to play for you.
Fox News host and perpetual Trump brown noser.
Maria BARTIROMO asks James Comer, Congressman,
is this treason?
And even Colmer isn't ready to go that far
yet.
Take a look.
Speaker 2: We need to know now who had access
to those documents because our national security
could be at risk.
Speaker 3: Well, I this is is this treason?
Speaker 2: It's it's very concerning.
We're not going to let up.
I think that we've got plenty of information
to move forward.
This would be a lot easier if the White House
would work with us.
Not only are they stonewalling our investigation,
you know, they're constantly if you watch
that press conference with the NSA guy, they
brought in that to fight back against the
investigators, which is preposterous because
this is the oversight committee.
We're supposed to provide oversight to the
government in the executive branch.
You know, it's nothing but much worse.
They need to slurs.
The American people can see through this.
The media is starting to see CNN TV.
Speaker 1: And the music is coming up very
quickly there.
So was Maria BARTIROMO asking whether it was
treason when it was Trump with hundreds of
documents after months of trying to keep them?
Right.
And I want you to think really, really carefully
about this, Biden having a small number of
documents left behind from when he was vice
president, which he didn't direct anyone to
take, which his lawyers found and immediately
called the National Archives and told them,
here's what we found.
We want to get it back to you and fully cooperating
with an investigation that might be treason.
On the other hand, Trump deliberately taking
hundreds of documents to his house, using
lawyers to obstruct the investigation, not
turning them over.
That is, of course, a witch hunt or something.
The double standard is breathtaking.
Breathtaking.
But it is not altogether surprising.
And I will again, I know people love to write
in and say, David, you're so biased on a lot
of the I am on the left.
Without a doubt, my views on issues when it
comes to taxation and the climate and education,
my views are on the left, there's no doubt
about it.
But I make every effort not to play these
games with you because actually, unlike the
Fox audience, which doesn't respect their
audience and is like, my audience is stupid,
will, they'll fall for anything we say, I
actually respect you.
And so I don't play the debt deficit games.
I don't play the gas price games.
And those parties, I don't do it.
And with this issue, I have said there are
some relevant, important differences between
the Trump and Biden classified documents situations.
Regardless, those differences should come
out in investigations that take place into
both of them.
So don't play those games with me.